la victoire du brésil contre l'allemagne
2 à 0 lors de la finale du championnat
du monde de football les deux buts ont
été marqués par ronaldo le brésil qui
remporte son cinquième titre mondial
les traditionnels aux du mois de juillet
alors que le smic sera augmentée
légalement de 2 4%
la consultation des médecins augmentera
tout comme la carte orange
une bonne nouvelle la gratuité des
retraits par carte bancaire dans la zone
euro pour les touristes français congrès
mondial des dermatologues de ma paris
plus de huit français sur dix souffrent
ou ont souffert de problèmes de peau
5000 spécialistes réunis autour de
thèmes comme celui de l'eczéma de
l'enfant alors que se déroulent les
défilés de la mode masculine la maison
chanel rachète quelques-uns des plus
grands ateliers de la haute couture les
broderies les plumes et les strass qui
menaçait de disparaître
voilà messieurs bonsoir l'actualité de
ce dimanche avec d'abord bien évidemment
la finale du mondial devant un stade
archicomble et des millions de
téléspectateurs le brésil obtenu sa
cinquième étoile emmené par ronaldo
l'équipe réputée pour son attaque
qu'elle n'a pas déçu bien au contraire
un parcours sans faute et de l'autre
côté
l'erreur fatale du capitaine de l'équipe
d'allemagne considéré pourtant comme le
meilleur des gardiens de but christophe
duchiron sort c'est du bonheur comme
s'il en pleuvait du bonheur à l'état pur
du bonheur de brésiliens qui règne sans
partage sur la planète football
ils sont seuls au monde les brésiliens
sur la piste au 5 étoiles un cinquième
titre de champion du monde qui dit mieux
personne ne dit mieux évidemment les
pronostiqueurs et c'est leur métier de
pronostiquer avait décrété que cette
finale serait un face à face ronaldo
oliver kahn et pour une fois les
pronostiqueurs avaient bien fait leur
métier face à face il lui met en
première période cela se résume à en un
festival de cannes de la chance quand il
en faut sur ce tir de kleberson car
cette fois l'allemand était dans les
choux
mais de la classe aussi sur cette
reprise de ronaldo résultat des courses
au repos les compteurs sont à zéro chez
des jaune et vert on crie on y croit dur
comme fer
chez le projet allemand au calme sa joie
et aux ménages ces pluies en début de
deuxième période on a cru qu'on était
reparti pour la guerre des gaules
on était sur ce coup franc de neuville
le gardien havrais
marcos mon cas l'occasion lui non plus
n'est pas manchot conclusion marco s'en
lave les mains et neuville s'en lave les
cheveux 67 minutes de jeu ronaldo fait
tout son possible pour récupérer le
ballon arrive à lui en profite et tirs
au but can relâche bêtement le ballon
ronaldo ouvre le score et ronald o
confiant qu'en football à l'âge de 25
ans on peut ressusciter
surtout que dix minutes plus tard le
2000 chauveau marque son 8e but de la
compétition
tout à sa joie les bras en croix le
brésil ronaldo bat l'allemagne oliver
kahn 2 à 0 je suis tellement content 10
et ronaldo après match ça fait tellement
bien après tout ce que j'ai vécu
c'était écrit dans la bible du ballon
rond qu'en 2002 jésus-christ le brésil
obtiendrait un cinquième titre de
champion du monde entre football et
religion
les brésiliens ont fini leur mondial par
une prière pour remercier jésus comme
qui dirait leurs premiers supporters un
pays en liesse et un pays qui sait faire
la fête le brésil retrouve ses victoires
d'antan et lave la défaite d'il ya
quatre ambiances euphorique dans les
rues de rio et les félicitations du
président brésilien cardozo le brésil a
montré dit il le meilleur football du
monde
et comme récompense ce sont tous les
fonctionnaires qui auront un jour férié
mardi prochain pour le retour de
l'équipe au pays
julien moment et didier deshamps sur la
plage de copacabana
cinq fois champion
certains ont encore du mal à réaliser
ils sont démunis sur la plage de
copacabana d'emilie s être levés tôt ici
le match commençait à 8 heures du matin
pas suffisant pour décourager les
brésiliens des brésiliens qui ne voulait
pas rester sur un échec
nous sommes tellement contents
aujourd'hui car la défaite de 81 18
elle nous reste en travers de la gorge
on en a gagné
on les attendait on était zéro on est
brésilien on est là le match j'en
termine et déjà les écharpes rappelant
les cinq victoires sont de sortie kemal
à c'en était trop
je ne pouvais plus regardées je
préférais écouter j'avais mon coeur qui
bat très fort
le brésil était sûr de sa victoire
immédiatement tout le monde s'est
retrouvé dans la rue centre ville
bloquée rue bondée concert de klaxons
ici tout prend des proportions
démesurées
pour ce qui est de célébrer ce titre
fait confiance au brésilien température
29 degrés et nous sommes encore que le
matin on attend encore beaucoup d'îliens
sur la course
et tout aussi ce n'est qu'un début les
cariocas
les habitants de rio ont maintenant ce
livre n'est charge des écoles de samba
dans les rues un défilé montaner à riom
le carnaval d'une fille aux voitures
difficile d'être parfaitement bons
joueurs évidemment la déception se lit
sur tous les visages en allemagne
patrice romedenne c'est ce qu'on appelle
avoir l'art du contre-pied bien que
perdant ils manifestent leur
satisfaction place de la victoire
même si le gros des troupes est resté
groggy devant son écran géant
à l'est le temps de se reprendre
l'allemand grands amateurs et
connaisseurs reste bon joueur malgré
tout il faut reconnaître le mérite de
cette équipe
elles terminent vice championne du monde
mais c'est vrai les brésiliens étaient
meilleurs ça ira demain ce sera oublié
j'espère qu'on gagnera en 2006 chez nous
rod steiger place réputée ponctuelle les
allemands avaient battu des records
aujourd'hui trois heures avant le coup
d'envoi on manquait déjà des espaces en
ce lieu qui n'a rien d'anodin et
symbolise la confiance retrouvée de
l'allemagne seulement voilà ronaldo
avait décidé de finir meilleur buteur du
mondial cela a au moins un avantage on
fait connaissance avec la communauté
brésilienne de berlin
la tristesse ne supportant allemand
masquer un désarroi plus profond qu'il
n'y paraît celui d'avoir manqué une
occasion rêvée de pouvoir manifester
sans que cela soit mal interprété leur
fierté d'être allemand il ya eu le
mondial de zidane il ya aujourd'hui
celui de ronaldo c'est lui qui a signé
les deux buts de cette finale et il
ramènera rio sa ville natale la
cinquième coupe du monde des larmes de
bonheur après le doute de ces dernières
années manuel tissier ronaldo pleure
comme un enfant comme un héros submergé
par le bonheur et les souvenirs sur la
pelouse de yokohama
les larmes du buteur renvoi quatre ans
en arrière un soir de tristesse au stade
de france
un 12 juillet 98 une autre finale ce
soir là barthez ne relâche pas le ballon
ronaldo est malade il a passé la matinée
à l'hôpital
il ne sait pas encore qu'il va y
retourner souvent novembre 99 son genou
lâche une première fois opéré à paris il
reprend la compétition six mois plus
tard trop tôt tous les amoureux du
football souffre avec ronaldo il va
travailler dur pour prouver qu'il peut
redevenir un phénomène de vélocité de
techniques le meilleur joueur du monde
ronaldo y croit et son chirurgien aussi
le brésilien offert une place pour la
finale à gérard saillant son sauveur
rencontre émouvante ce matin celui à
deux ans du même oeil
ronaldo de retour et c'est une bonne
nouvelle car son génie est unique
tout beau tout neuf il plane à nouveau
sur le toit du monde
nous vous le disions le brésil est
habillée avec cette victoire un nouveau
record 5 étoiles cinq titres mondiaux
pour une équipe qui n'était pas donné
comme super favorite il ya un mois
christophe portera l'histoire d'amour
entre le brésil et la coupe du monde
débute en suède en 1958 les spectateurs
découvrent un gamin de 17 ans et 8 mois
edson arantes do nascimento dit pelé une
légende est née il ainsi deux buts en
finale et permet à son pays de remporter
enfin le trophée jules rimet une
victoire célébrée dans tout le pays
déjà le tour de la ville le bonheur la
gloire et ce n'est pas tout alan
d'honneur décoration et dons de toutes
sortes argent propriété tomber les mains
des plaies et varades et pipi dans les
noms sont aujourd'hui pour le brésil et
non de héros nationaux quatre ans plus
tard au chili pelé s'est blessé dans le
deuxième match
il suivra la coupe du monde des tribunes
ce qui n'empêche pas ses coéquipiers de
conserver le trophée
les garrincha dit divas sont également
mes joueurs d'exception
la coupe c'est l'orgueil du pays miral
président de la république elle c'est
oublier les difficultés économiques aux
brésiliens pensent cela elle est plus
importante que le riz en 1970 au stade
aztèque de mexico
l'équipe du brésil qui s'impose face à
l'italie est la plus forte de l'histoire
peu les buteurs et les passeurs à
bientôt 30 ans il joue sa dernière coupe
du monde et il offre à son pays le droit
de conserver à tout jamais le trophée
jules rimet
en 1994 aux états unis seule la victoire
est belle
longa soulève la coupe le brésil
s'impose aux tirs au but encore face à
l'italie il y avait 0-0 à la fin du
temps réglementaire la suite de
l'histoire s'est déroulée cet après midi
avec désormais cinq étoiles sur le
maillot
l'équipe du brésil est la plus titrée au
monde
la fierté de tout un peuple et à paris
il y avait de l'ambiance où se
mélangeaient dans un même bonheur
supporteurs brésiliens et français il
est vrai que ronaldinho le milieu de
terrain brésilien jô psg diego garcia
neymar à paris en vert et jaune au
rythme de la samba
bienvenue à copacabana sur scène avant
même le match ils croient déjà à la
victoire
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour pour le
brésil comme une revanche 2 à 0
c'est l'explosion de joie une joie sans
retenue après la tension du match il se
relâche
ils n'ont jamais douté de leur équipe
j'ai vu la force le courage ferveur
d'élire les supporteurs du brésil ont
mis du temps à rentrer dans la coupe du
monde
aujourd'hui il se rattrape
et ils l'ont fait le brésil au firmament
de la planète foot exulte cinquième
titre de champion du monde ça se fait
avec un brin de provocation pour
certains soleil tueur samba et le brésil
sur le toit du monde
pour les vert et or la fête ne fait que
commencer
les traditionnels aux du 1er juillet
certes il y avait un côté par exemple la
revalorisation légale du smic mais pas
de coup de pouce et de l'autre des
augmentations comme celle de la carte
orange ou encore des consultations
médicales dont nous vous parlons depuis
quelques semaines le point avec
elisabeth islamique pas de coup de pouce
supplémentaire cette année mais juste
l'augmentation légale +2 4% ce qui fait
passer le salaire minimum horaire brut
de 6 euros 67,6 euros être ventes en
hausse des cotisations sociales pour
faire face au déficit de l'assurance
chômage
elles augmentent de 2 % à la fois pour
les salariés et pour les employeurs
demain c'est aussi l'entrée en vigueur
des nouveaux honoraires des médecins
généralistes
la consultation passe à 20 euros la
visite à domicile à 30 euros et comme
chaque année le 1er juillet changements
de tarifs des transports en
ile-de-france la carte orange augmente
de 3 68%
le poupon deux jaunes coûtera désormais
46 euros et cinq sentiers enfin au rayon
des baisses cette fois trois célèbres
fabricants de cigarettes changent leurs
prix à partir de demain pour certains -
10 centimes d'euros en moyenne une
baisse dénoncée par les associations de
lutte contre le tabagisme parmi les
bonnes nouvelles au 1er juillet les
retrait et paiement par carte bancaire
seront désormais gratuits pour les
français lorsqu'ils se rendront dans la
zone euro une réglementation européenne
qu'est comme principe de se calquer sur
la réglementation du pays concerné david
bouyre dans le centre de rome
quelques touristes françaises en
goguette certains se sont mis rapidement
à l'heure italienne
si elle se fait pirater on est pirates
1000 euros au delà du pirate est la
carte complète a et aura
il faut dire qu'en italie le billet de
banque reste le principal moyen de
paiement et pour nos touristes français
il vaut mieux emporté en voyage
elias d'euros car jusqu'à maintenant
utiliser sa carte bancaire en europe
n'était pas gratuit les banques
françaises appliquée en moyenne une
commission de 0.5 % pour les paiements
et jusqu'à 7% pour les retraits aux
distributeurs des frais qui doivent
disparaître à partir du 1er juillet
c'est plutôt encourageant
on a amené de plus en plus à voyager en
europe ça va faciliter les échanges
c'est tout à fait normal qu'on puisse
une paye et de la même façon partout
celle avantage pour nous les européens
un nouveau règlement européen oblige en
fait les banques à appliquer les mêmes
tarifs dans l'ensemble de la zone euro
que dans leur propre pays
une bonne nouvelle donc pour les
français car chez nous l'utilisation de
la carte est gratuite pour le
consommateur les opérations à l'étranger
représentent que 2 % des transactions
pour les banques est français c'est
c'est beaucoup et en même temps peut
maintenant il est vrai que comme l'état
que les commissions était importante à
l'étranger c'est un manque à gagner que
les banques et cherchons sûrement à
compenser des banquiers qui n'ont pas
encore réagi
toutefois certains grands réseaux
facture déjà les retraits d'argent
effectués dans les distributeurs d'une
autrement une pratique qui risquent à
l'avenir de se généraliser
à partir de demain s'il vous reste des
francs vous serez obligé de vous rendre
à la banque de france pour les changer
et c'est vrai que six mois après la mise
en circulation de l'euro
il reste une vingtaine de milliards de
francs qui dorment dans les coffres sous
les matelas ou dans les vitrines des
collectionneurs à 6 8 % des billets de
500 francs n'ont pas encore été changée
en euro 5 % des billets de 100 francs et
pour les petites coupures 48% des
billets de 20 francs je vous rappelle
les délais de récupération auprès donc
dé la bande de france 3 ans pour les
pièces et 10 ans pour les billets à moi
studieux pour les parlementaires qui
travailleront jusqu'au 3 août prochain
tout commencera par le discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
mardi prochain on sait déjà que dans
l'opposition c'est françois hollande qui
lui répondra autre certitude un message
du chef de l'etat sera lu dans
l'hémicycle arnaud goûter alexandre kara
parce qu'il aime les petites phrases
jean pierre raffarin parle désormais du
temps de l'action le gouvernement veut
aller vite mais dès mardi
c'est le nouveau président de
l'assemblée qui ouvre le bal jean louis
debré doit lire devant les députés un
message jacques chirac car le président
de la république n'est pas autorisée à
s'exprimer au parlement
deuxième étape mercredi jean pierre
raffarin prononce son discours de
politique générale cette responsabilité
je l'acceptent en 97
lionel jospin a évoqué la responsabilité
il ventait la république lanceront dans
une époque nouvelle en 69
jacques chaban delmas présenter sa
nouvelle société
la déclaration c'est l'acte fondateur de
tout gouvernement
jean pierre raffarin devrait parler
sécurité dialogue social en juillet la
cession s'annonce chargé cinq projets de
loi
le premier concerne la mystique des
petites infractions routières et pénales
et ne devrait pas aller plus loin je ne
souhaite pas que dans le cas d'une loi
d'amnistié puisse y avoir une amnistie
politico-financières c'est très clair
puis vient le texte sur la sécurité
avant le collectif budgétaire qui
portera notamment sur une baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu de 5 %
ensuite il ya la justice et l'aide à
l'emploi des jeunes en entreprise
dans l'opposition les socialistes ne
sont pas convaincus par le 1er mai
il le proclame qu'il est à l'écouté de
la france du bas et il n'agit que pour
ceux qui sont au plus haut la décision
était prise en conseil des ministre jean
pierre raffarin va réclamer un vote de
confiance à tous les députés
mais le résultat ne fait aucun doute car
la droite dispose de la majorité absolue
encore ces nationalistes qui ont décidé
cette semaine délire prochainement une
assemblée nationale provisoire
ce projet leur semble une étape
nécessaire mais on retiendra de ce
dimanche à corte l'image plutôt inédite
de charles pieri sortie de prison aux
côtés de jean guy talamoni deux
personnages clés du mouvement
indépendantiste qui semble à présent
réunis sous la même bannière le charles
de gaulle de retour de mission c'est
demain que le porte-avions accostera
dans la rade de toulon sa première
opération après les attentats du 11
septembre était de sécuriser la région
autour de l'afghanistan
sept mois en mer est prévue dans
l'après-midi de ma la visite de jacques
chirac à bord thierry kurt et une
première sortie opérationnelle très
longue
c'est moi mais ce matin les senteurs de
6 il rappelait que le porte-avions
nucléaire se rapprocher de toulon signe
ultime que la mission est terminée
le charles de gaulle a renvoyé son
groupe aérien en france
les pilotes salue les deux milles marins
du bord en formant une croix de lorraine
sur le pont déjà un petit air de
vacances
pour nous ça veut dire ça sent le retour
on sent la maison sans déjà l'odeur de
la provence et de la france parce qu'en
fait c'est la france il manque tout
simplement de machines armand 130
il éclaire ici qu'on a oublié au douar
des débuts difficiles du porte-avions le
commandant ne les évoque plus du tout il
n'a en tête que le bilan de la mission
qui s'achève
on a débuté dans techniques qu'humaines
non non je suis pas repartir vous êtes
peut-être prêt à repartir mais ce que le
bâtiment est ce que les hommes sont
prêts à repartir dont il pas besoin de
souffler l'un et l'autre ils ont bien
sûr une nécessité ils ont envie de
souffler bien sûr mais est ce qu'il y
avait un impératif techniques de
maintenance non le commandant estime
qu'il aurait pu tenir la mer encore six
mois
le charles de gaulle a parcouru
l'équivalent de trois tours du monde
depuis 1er décembre c'est demain que
s'ouvre devant la cour d'assises du nord
le procès d'un policier qui a
mortellement touché à lille la jeune
algérien en avril 2000 on notera que
dans cette affaire l'homme est poursuivi
pour homicide involontaire une
accusation extrêmement rares le rappel
des faits yasmina farber cancer ou la
dent stéphane en dolina sort de ce
commissariat escorté par ses collègues
il sait déjà qu'il sera mise en examen
pour homicide volontaire
c'est exceptionnel pour un policier en
patrouille dans la banlieue sud de lille
le maître chien de 27 ans et son
coéquipier sont alertés pour un vol de
voiture
deux jeunes gens sont dans le véhicule
l'un d'eux ryad hamlaoui se baissent
stéphane en all-in à panic cir est une
jeune homme il n'était pas armé pour la
justice ce n'est pas de la légitime
défense quand on arrive qu'on keira très
près de la nuque un puce donc derrière
de très près
c'est pourquoi pour tuer le policier et
écroué
mais cette décision ne pèse pas les
tensions le jour les manifestations de
soutien à ryad m là où dégénère et
pendant trois nuits consécutives
la banlieue de lille va s'embraser deux
ans plus tard la cour d'assises va
examiner les raisons de cette dramatique
perte de sang froid
était ce par exemple à la brigade canine
d'effectuer cette intervention
la famille de la victime attend des
réponses claires non seulement de
l'accusé mais aussi de sa hiérarchie
toute cette fin de semaine nous vous
avons parlé de ces interpellations de
ressortissants roumains soupçonnés
d'être à l'origine d'un réseau de
mendicité utilisant des handicapés ou
prétendus tels parfois mineures à nice
et à grenoble
huit personnes ont été mises en examen
et écrouées
que d'émotions et de souvenirs pour ces
quatre lorrain qui soixante ans après
son revenu en russie pour rendre hommage
à leurs camarades morts en détention ces
français que l'on appelle les malgré
nous avaient été mobilisés de force est
obligé d'aller servir sur le front russe
sous l'uniforme allemand hier le conseil
général de moselle leur a offert ce
voyage du recueillement correspondance
de nick berda sur les pavés de la place
rouge
l'ombre du souvenir plus d'un demi
siècle après la fin de leur calvaire
c'est une autre russie que découvre ses
anciens combattants venus en pèlerinage
aujourd'hui ça vous fait quoi d'être là
suis heureux est en cours de seconde et
d'être parmi vous
et de venir en touriste ça dépend
complètement est un homme libre ou
sérieuses comme un sacré cadeau reiser
show
ces hommes sont des malgré-nous ils font
partie des 130 milles alsaciens et
mosellans qui à partir d'août 40 de
surtemps relais de force dans l'armée
allemande est envoyé sur le front russe
prisonniers ou déserteurs ils se
retrouvent entassés dans des wagons à
bestiaux et expédié à tambov à 500 km de
moscou
au total ce sont près de 20 mille
français qui furent détenus dans le camp
188 1 caen semblable à celui ci où
chaque jour le froid la faim et la
maladie emportait les plus faibles
plus de la moitié d'entre eux sont morts
dans la forêt de rada et si la
marseillaise résonne à la mémoire de
leurs camarades disparus
les malgré nous attendent toujours que
l'histoire leur rende enfin un véritable
hommage officiel
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez le
sentiment compte que la france reconnaît
votre sacrifice pas encore et non pas
tout à fait me sentir bien pu oublier
oui c'est pour ça que je vous avais dit
mon dernier combat c'est celui là encore
est reconnu par le gouvernement français
à leur retour en france en 1945 ou 46 il
n'y avait ni tambour ni trompette pour
accueillir ceux qui contre leur gré
avait porté l'uniforme allemand et seul
leur famille blu ray les malgré-nous qui
ne sont jamais revenus
le danemark prend à partir de deux mâles
la présidence de l'union européenne
parmi les dossiers à traiter celui de la
pêche qui intéresse plus que tout autre
ce pays qui est le premier pêcheur en
europe le danemark qui pratiquent une
pêche intensive et industrielle pour
l'aquaculture poehl de genève
josé boulesteix ce chalutier est si
lourd qu'il semble presque coulé dans
ses cales 600 tonnes de poisson ici un
bateau de pêche en remplace un autre sur
les quais d'esbjerg ni crier ni camion
frigorifique
mais une usine ces tuyaux aspire
directement de minuscules poissons des
lançon c'est le royaume de la pêche
industrielle
selon le projet de réforme européenne le
danemark devra également détruire une
partie de ses bateaux mais ce n'est pas
ce qui inquiète le plus la seule chose
qui nous inquiète vraiment c'est que les
pêcheurs français ou espagnol
n'obtiennent pas de la commission
européenne
le même quota de bateaux à détruire que
nous les pêcheurs danois
dans ces immenses filet près d'un
million de tonnes de spratt ou de lançon
sont pêchés chaque année une pêche
intensive dénoncée par les pêcheurs
français mais justifiée par les danois
nous perturbons également
l'environnement avec la pêche
industrielle pas les espèces de poissons
prélevés pour cette pêche industrielle
le son dans une limite qui respecte
l'environnement biologique chez ces
poissons n'iront pas sur les marchés
impropre à la consommation humaine
ils sont cuits broyer séché au bout de
la chaîne de la farine
cette usine tourne 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 220 mille tonnes de cette
farine sont produites chaque année de
l'huile aussi pour des médicaments des
cosmétiques le danemark exporte cette
farine dans le monde entier pour
l'élevage mais surtout pour
l'aquaculture
il faut entre 4 et 5 kg de poissons
frais transformé ensuite en farine pour
l'aquaculture pour obtenir en bout de
chaîne un kilo disons de saumon
d'élevage
cela fait 50 ans que les danemark s'est
spécialisé dans cette pêche industrielle
une position aujourd'hui idéal dans une
europe qui veut réduire le nombre de ces
pêcheurs traditionnels
le congrès mondial de dermatologie
s'ouvre demain à paris un événement dans
le monde médical 5000 spécialistes
réunis autour de ces affections qui
concerne plus de 8 français sur 10 qui
affirment souffrir ou avoir souffert de
problèmes de peau parmi les thèmes
abordés celui de l'eczéma de l'enfant
qui embarrasse bien des parents et
pauriol laquelle il existe pourtant des
traitements jean daniel flaysakier
massant bouffartigue dans la famille
fernandes les problèmes de peau ont
connu à sept mois
justine une dermatite atopique
c'est-à-dire un eczéma du visage propre
nourrisson adeline la cadette n'a rien
sur la peau mais elle est asthmatique
céline neuf en revanche a elle aussi un
examen cela fait six ans que céline
souffrent de ce trouble de l'immunité si
bobo la démanche souvent et quand elle
se grattent à l'école certains de ses
copains ne sont pas très compréhensible
ajoutait que ces craintes étaient bien
tu as envie que ça s'attrape pas à me
fortin et crois pas
inc raspaillou 20% des enfants français
souffrent d'atopie à terme qui recouvre
rhume des foins asthme et excellent
pompiers et elle a des lunettes que
voyez sur métal et alain examen des
paupières pour le traitement des lésions
de la peau il y ait des crèmes contenant
des dérivés de la cortisone efficace
dans 98% des cas elles sont absolument
sans danger mais elles sont souvent mal
utilisé le mot cortisone et frais les
parents 19h affreuse est tous là tous
les gens de l'entourage leur dise que
c'est très dangereux et on les
culpabilise encore une fois là on leur
disant vous mettez des corticoïdes
il va avoir de l'asthme il va voir s'il
va voir ça tout ça bien entendu ces cds
ce sont des fantaisies de gens qui ne
connaissent rien mais tout le monde
participe à répandre ses idées hormis
certaines situations particulières il
est également inutile de faire la chasse
aux allergènes enlever la moquette
changer la literie éviter les fleurs n'a
aucun effet sur l'eczéma
l'enfant doit vivre dans un
environnement le plus normale possible
dans quelques mois de nouvelles crèmes
sans corticoïdes vont arriver sur le
marché
en attendant même si c'est contraignant
il faut continuer à placer la pommade et
avec l'adolescence qui pointe céline a
une motivation toute trouvée
j'espère pour débarrasser rapidement de
ces petits bobos là mais tant qu'à
chacune
comment passer ses vacances en utilisant
l'euro à bonne escient l'exemple de
belgique où les touristes français
s'adapte petit à petit julie benzoni
dominique maes alors qu'on vient vous
doit-on pour une demi-heure 11e rang
français au moins 0 belge pour les
touristes de la panne dans les flandres
l'habitude de convertir et tenace et en
attendant que l'euro devienne un réflexe
chacun essaye d'y trouver son compte
anne ou encore nous sommes jeunes donc
ça nous pose pas problème ça ne posait
pas de problème de convertir mais c'est
vrai que pour les personnes âgées c'est
beaucoup plus simple oui il tarifs pas
de problème pas de souci d'être roulés
accès plus facilement l'impression de
dépenser moins et en fait on dépense
plus pourquoi on ne peut s'en serait pas
c'est plus rien et on fait quand on fait
la conversion on se rend compte que
c'est pas pour rien du tout attention
donc euro ou pas avec le soleil les
vacances les billets s'évapore des
porte-monnaie pour atterrir dans la
caisse de mireille moi je trouve que
sauf simple pour tout le monde parce que
ils partent en vacances les eaux leurs
monnaies ils doivent plus à la banque
faut pas changer quoi leroux donne des
idées voyage à certains moins de tracas
plus de calculette et un sentiment
nouveau l'impression de ne plus être
seulement un citoyen français
au fait j'ai souvent l'europe et pour la
première fois on s'est senti en europe
c'est à dire on avait un langage commun
c'est l'euro ont parlé de ces thèmes
dans les vitrines c'était marqué 9 45
euros
ce point commun les touristes belges le
ressentent aussi quand ils viennent en
france même s'il n'y a que 15 km à faire
il s'avoue dépaysé
grâce à la france et de belgique c'est
la belgique et quand on vient ici en
rang en france lui en étant par
l'écologie aller à l'étranger tout en
restant chez soi c'est peut-être ça
l'europe de demain
les premiers jours de vacances pour les
juillettistes avec l'engouement des
français pour la navigation de plaisance
au point que les ports traditionnels
n'arrive plus à trouver de place sa
bande de lieux on a contourné le
problème en créant un port à sec
olivier ferrand hervé pozzo sur un
plateau c'est un peu le principe du port
à sec
lorsque le plaisancier veut sortir en
promenade rien de plus simple un coup de
filet la capitainerie et ça y est je
viens je demande à ce qu'on sorte ce
bateau et puis normalement ça se passe
assez rapidement le bateau est à plomb
dans les maximums un quart d'heure vingt
minutes le capitaine et l'équipage n'ont
alors plus qu'à embarquer la promenade
commence par une dizaine de minutes de
navigation sur la siagne un fleuve
côtier l'occasion de reprendre le bateau
en main un dernier pont et la
méditerranée est là la baie de cannes
les îles de lérins la mer enfin comme
ils sont 800 à avoir préféré le port à
sec de monde au lieu
le concept est américain il est arrivé
en france il ya douze ans déjà les ports
traditionnels commencé à être saturé il
ya un problème de place dans les ports
traditionnels de la côte d'azur et de la
france entière problème qui ne fait que
s'aggraver depuis qu'il a glissé la loi
littoral qui limite pour ne pas dire qui
interdit la l'extension des ports
existants et la construction de nouveaux
porte donc le principe du port à sec est
une solution alternative avec des prix
légèrement inférieur aux prix pratiqués
dans les ports traditionnels le port à
sec est lui aussi victime du succès il
affiche déjà complet
c'est parce que l'hiver justement il est
au sec
on a facilité d'accès de nettoyer de
carpentras plus économique plus
écologique
de nombreuses villes de méditerranée de
l'atlantique sont intéressés par le
concept de port à sec déjà un deuxième
port inland a été mise en service à
hyères dans le var
toujours des perturbations à orly sud
depuis 48 heures la grève du zèle des
agents de sûreté continue d'entraîner
des retards de plus d'une heure sur
presque tous les vols à orly ouest
semble suivre le mouvement depuis ce
matin ce mouvement social pourrait
d'ailleurs faire tache d'huile à partir
de jeudi à roissy
les agents de sûreté ior déposés après
une grève illimitée à quelques jours du
tour de france déroulé le championnat de
france de cyclisme sur route l'occasion
dans les hautes-alpes de tester la forme
des français julien jean voilà l'été les
championnats de france et le sourire de
la famille lui rend à une semaine de la
grande boucle
on le dit en grande forme mais pour
l'instant chaque chose en son temps
richard virenque pense d'abord au
maillot bleu blanc rouge ces maillots
bleus donnent même voilà je suis là pour
l'âge le prêt si juteux
j'en fais à fond les coureurs passent
les années aussi hélas virenque manière
ne semble pas avoir pris une ride
ils sont une cinquantaine venus de toute
la france venu à briançon pour
encourager richard essentiellement
richard c'est clair et le vélo parce que
le vélo roller me faire par contre
j'aime beaucoup
richard un richard virenque au bon coup
de [ __ ] des supporters au bord de la
route et les alpes en toile de fond lors
de ces championnats
il y a comme un avant-goût de tour de
france à l'arrivée c'est le jeune
nicolas vos bonnes ce qui devance au
sprint nicolas jalabert et ses autres
partenaires d'échappée
je remercie tout le monde
voilà il ya mon père la mère mon frère
tout ça qui sont venus est très très
content de gagner devant à 24 ans
devenir champion de france c'est du
bonheur et à une semaine du tour ça
donne sûrement des haines place aux
jeunes talents lors de ne pas toujours
l'occasion de se produire à côté de
festivals comme celui d'aix ou d'orange
un concert était donné aujourd'hui par
de jeunes musiciens à l'hôpital
bretonneau à paris olivier les mises à
delphine de tri
un produit de jeune surdoué sortie du
conservatoire national supérieur de
musique les grands festivals les ignore
alors ils se produisent notamment dans
des hôpitaux à l'invitation de
l'association jeunes talents la
difficulté quand on sort du
conservatoire c'est que on est de plus
en plus à jouer bien et que des
festivals comme jeunes talents c'est sûr
que ça nous aide à faire connaître
rencontrer un public à faire des
rencontres aussi parmi les musiciens
avec qui on va jouer plus tard je vous
laisse accueillir mathieu godefroy et
patrick langot je vous souhaite un très
bon concert
une heure de concert au programme haydn
caudalie ravenne et si on ressent
beaucoup beaucoup de gentillesse
beaucoup de vous beaucoup d'amour dans
ce qu'on fait c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et qui permet aux
malades qui n'ont qui sont un petit peu
repliés sur eux-mêmes de s'ouvrir au zoo
de s'ouvrir à la musique la musique
c'est quelque chose de merveilleux
un récital à l'hôpital
le temps d'une après midi une
cinquantaine de personnes ont voyagé au
son de la musique classique un dimanche
ensoleillé
et puis quelques notes qui en réchauffer
un peu plus les coeurs et les âmes
les défilés de la mode masculine depuis
hier à paris aujourd'hui sur le podium
la collection d'helmut lang après cinq
ans d'absence il revient dans la
capitale
le couturier qui d'ordinaire était
plutôt minimaliste signe une collection
faite au spectaculaire
il a reçu de nombreux prix a marqué de
son emprunte depuis plusieurs années la
mode 2 masculine mode encore mais dans
un tout autre registre la haute couture
sauve les petits ateliers ainsi chanel
vient de racheter le célèbre brodeur
lesage et d'autres maisons célèbres pour
leurs plumes et leurs fleurs ce sens les
plus grands parures et du monde
il risquait de disparaître estelle cola
grégory vasseur ici on est encore au 19e
siècle 25 petites mains à la dextérité
fabuleuse liste plumes d'autruche
oiseaux de paradis et aigrettes au gré
des caprices couture redonner vie à
quelques 700 vautours et 200 faisans
dans un manteau de plumes d'yves saint
laurent
voilà toute la vie de ses plus grands
pas oublié du monde commanderait lemarié
des hommes de l'ombre qui participent à
la gloire des collections le stock était
constituée au fil des ans et nous avons
des oiseaux qui ont ils n'existent plus
ou qu'on ne chasse plus parce qu'ils
sont ultra protégée de ces ateliers sont
sortis des chefs-d'oeuvre comme ici les
vestes bande blog d'yves saint laurent
ou encore les robes coromandel de chanel
elle savoir faire vieux d'un siècle
en résumant pour le célèbre brodeur
françois lesage ses 9 millions d'heures
de travail
soixante mille échantillons et 40 tonnes
de perles paillettes des passementeries
ici aussi on ne fait que du sur mesure
la fameuse sandale déjà boulenouar copia
10 millions d'exemplaires c'est lui lui
aussi devra bientôt penser à l'avenir de
sa maison quand on est parti comme dans
cet artisanat chaussures ou d'autres
dans la mode
on peut plus s'arrêter le paradoxe c'est
qu'on aime qu'on est passionné et on
voudrait comme on dit mourir sur la
scène aujourd'hui
chanel a donc décidé de protéger
l'avenir de ses doigts d'or en rachetant
ces maisons sans successeur c'est se
termine ce journal je vous remercie de
votre attention tout de suite la météo
patrice drevet 20h50 les spécialistes un
film de patrice leconte avec bernard
giraudeau et gérard lanvin 23h30 le
dernier journal lève mettait trésor
daniel bilalian 20h david pujadas
excellente soirée sur france 2 on se
quitte avec ses images de steve fossett
à bord de son ballon qui a entamé le
dernier tiers de son tour du monde en
solitaire et s'éloigne maintenant de la
côte est de l'afrique du sud